[Music]
[Applause]
if you haven't already gotten a copy of
roger bennett's number one new york
times bestseller reborn in the usa an
englishman's love letter to his chosen
home please do available online wherever
books are sold
and the star one of the stars of ben and
blazers co-host on
nbcsports.com he's a podcaster filmmaker
all-around good guy and we thought
we got some drama here going on in
soccer right now and uh wait you're
wearing a chicago bear's hat
old school bear's hat
super bowl 20 bears hat it's happening
this is no it's not by the way when you
said in your recap which i had to listen
to when you said the bears i think they
could be average i've got to be honest
i'd bite your arm off for average right
now i really really would i'm feeling
quite bullish this is i love the way you
noticed the hat
and you didn't notice that i didn't even
know it was meat friday and good lord
here i am dressed for it in my uh in my
meat friday taxi you have an arby's
tracksuit and it looks like a piece of
roast beef there have i i've actually
got it's a full track suit i i i wrote
in my book about how the first time as a
15 year old i ate orbeez and just the
taste of that beef dip tasted like
democracy and freedom and so the lo and
behold are these possibly the greatest
press they've had in about 30 years um i
received from arby's a full meat track
suit which i wear
often
and uh your producers just told me i
look like lady gaga
well she did have that outfit when she
actually had meat as her outfit yeah she
was she wore it well we weren't even
doing who wore it better i'll give it to
her i look like a bull i'll take it i'll
be the bald lady gaga but it's a joy to
be with you on meat fridays as football
the world of football eats itself down
patrick um you know before we get to uh
soccer here i went on my honeymoon to
london in scotland and when i got in
uh
the food was horrible
so this is i'm coming up on my 34th
wedding anniversary uh this weekend and
i just remember i ate at pizza hut
almost
the whole time i was in london has the
food gotten better in london when you
said pizza hut
15 year old me was like oh that's a
humble brag
in england when i grew up i want you to
know pizza hut was a michelin starred
restaurant
i only had one or two stars you know in
my book i write about when mcdonald's
opened when i was a kid in liverpool we
would drive for hours to go to the
nearest mcdonald's like you would drive
for three or four hours it would be like
oh my god there'd be a line around the
block you'd see the golden arches and it
would be like the simpsons oh noise you
dropped to your knees you would wait
patiently you get to the front the
person would be like what do you want
you'll be like what do you mean what i
want i want the whole bloody menu and
then you would sit there for hours until
a food coma of just meat gristle and
utter crap had filled your belly and you
looked at the styrofoam castle that was
in front of you and you were like
america
you ain't the best you at the best of
what that's where your marriage has
lasted 34 years you set expectations
today
all right as you uh point out football
has gone a bit bonkers here oh my god
where are we right now with with with
cristiano ronaldo
i don't know cristiano ronaldo who your
viewers may know is really essentially a
bottle of draconoir made into human
flesh one of the world's greatest
footballers 36 years old now i mean just
uh and still an elite athlete still
scoring goals his game has changed he's
no longer the all-round footballer who
can dominate games he now kind of hangs
around the area on the counter scores a
ton um he wants away from juventus he
said his goodbyes to italian powerhouse
juventus i imagine him sitting sitting
on a plane uh just idling on the tarmac
trying to work out where the heck he's
going to go probably plucking his
eyebrows to kill the time and right now
world football has become insane you
remember the super league don't you dab
you remember cast your mind about those
many years ago that's what it feels like
to the super the super league failed
that was a but now what i realized is
the super league was really an effort by
the second level of superpower teams
many of them owned by american owners
liverpool
arsenal manchester united you know even
barcelona
and real madrid they felt threatened by
the upper echelon of super super teams
psg paris saint-germain chelsea
and also manchester city one owned by an
oligarch the other two owned by
sovereign states who have limitless
financing that no one else can keep up
with and they have essentially stretched
the market they're willing to pay wages
beyond belief no one else can compete
and so the reality is with cristiano
ronaldo who is really more a instagram
platform than a footballer he's an
excellent footballer but just the
instagram the social media
brand platform that he is that's why
teams currently want him more than
anything there's very few places that he
can actually go it was thought he was
going to go to manchester city um which
has already got just a glut of uh uh uh
so now it's manchester united yeah yeah
i mean his chaos is allowed the world
football dam has essentially become the
equivalent of watching bezos
branson and musk compete to send phallic
rockets towards the moon there's like
three three teams we're essentially just
cheering for excel balance sheets would
you rather would you rather have messi
or ronaldo
i'd rather have do i have a young
gentleman with a huge right now there's
a player unbapped about to leave paris
and germany go to real madrid because
messi has arrived these two are massive
brand platforms they're incredibly aged
deep respect to tom brady going to tampa
bay but football is at such a cohesive
game you need players at the elite level
who can now play both ends play
90 minutes backwards and for neither of
those gentlemen can do it i adore messi
in this argument essentially there's two
kinds of fans those who do believe in
plucking their eyebrows deeply those who
don't if you're in the former you adore
and revere the god like ronaldo if you
don't you love the super cuts approach
to life uh of lionel messi
we are blessed we are blessed to have
been alive to watch both of them men
play and when they both go you know
we've taken their just consistent
superlative
excellence for granted but they're both
now in a situation where they are so big
there's only one or two clubs they can
go to there's essentially a secret vip
room within football's vip room and
that's where they've both got themselves
into but god bless them both they've
given us incredible thrills i don't know
where ronaldo is going to go and that
idea of him on the plane just anxiously
waiting and my lord if that plane ends
up in mls in america it will be
hilarious
oh
he's not ready for that yet uh you know
the the reality is there could be a plan
c if manchester united i've got a
feeling manchester united will take him
for a variety of reasons manchester
united owned by the tampa bay uh owners
the glazers that's where he came through
as a youth it's a fine fitting legacy to
end his career they truly need a
gentleman their team is highly paid it's
got so many stars it's not quite
cohesive i mean it'll just be it'll be
hilarious to watch him uh wash up there
but very soon very soon both of those
gentlemen uh could well come here
because mls is not a footballing
challenge but to dominate america that
final brand play for your legacy to come
here and set up a brand deal with sheet
weights
ronaldo doing a [ __ ] weight commercial
uh rgbc god that will be that will be i
did that as [ __ ] weights just be clear
america that is that is the future that
i want to see better career ronaldo or
tom brady
dan i mean they're both they have both
rewritten uh our understanding um of
aging athletes they are both superlative
competitors they are both you know so
disciplined um in their approach to the
game all right
they're better looking better looking
uh four that would be
oh that one that one you know the
reality is i believe
i believe and i've only met him once
ronaldo still has all of his own hat so
i am you know
as a bet
as a bears fan
one of the things that upsets me most in
life dan patrick is i love the city of
chicago it's my spiritual home i yearn
to be there and whenever i land at the
airport as i did a couple of weeks ago
to go and throw out a picture of the
white sox
you land you have that joy of being home
and then all the way in on the road from
the airport to the city you are taunted
by brian urlach at pitching uh hair
transplants
and there's nothing that annoys me
because that man i idolized that man
bulldozer was put him on the pedestal
newly freshly fakely haired brighter
like
frankly he's got a bit off the rails and
so i do think like if you if you if you
go into that if you steroid your hair
you do lose style points so i've got to
go i've got to go with ronnie uh but
both of those human beings ultimately
what you worship is that menthol that
that the rage eating of one almond when
you lose a game allowing that kind of
discipline um is is why what i revere
about there it's the opposite of me
essentially in my meeting orbeez tracksy
i love it uh hey congrats on the book
it's great to talk to you you you
cleared it all up there we we know
exactly what's going on in soccer right
now yeah i mean essentially it's bezos
it's
ransom it's musk it's phallic rockets to
the moon
thank you buddy
and mazel tov on your wedding 34 years
ago dan patrick courage good jontiff
much much knackers uh roger bennett uh
men and blazers co-host on nbcsports.com
and uh the number one new york times
bestseller reborn in the usa